summer 2020 is finally almost here and
Netflix is serving up a ton of new
viewing options for the month of June
some excellent selections will be
hitting the streamer in every genre and
of course there will also be plenty of
original fare here's all of the best
stuff coming to Netflix in June 2020 the
faction is your bag Netflix has you
covered in June 2020 hitting the
streamer on the 1st of June is a quartet
of awesome flicks
first there's the 2012 military action
or act of valor which follows the
efforts of a Navy SEAL team to track
down a group of dangerous terrorists on
June 1st will also see Spike Lee's
acclaimed heist flick Inside Man which
sports an absolutely stellar cast
featuring the likes of Denzel Washington
Jodie Foster and Clive Owen recently I
plan and set in motion events to execute
the perfect bank robbery if you're in
the mood for something with a little
less gritty realism and a little more
flying farm animals there's the 1996
action classic twister
Twister stars Helen Hunt in the late
great bill paxton as husband and wife
storm chasers who tangle with tornadoes
of escalating intensity twister hits
Netflix on the 1st of June along with
the Wachowskis V for Vendetta finally
there's the Netflix original lost bullet
a French language flick in which an
ex-con mechanic comes under suspicion
for murder the only thing that can clear
his name is a bullet lodged in a missing
car lost bullet arrives on June 19th
there are only two truly great sci-fi
selections coming to Netflix in June
2020 and it's safe to say that they
couldn't be more different from each
other however they're both stone called
classics made by directors who execute
their visions perhaps better than anyone
else in the business the first of these
is the beloved 1982 film ET the
extra-terrestrial directed by Steven
Spielberg which centers on the efforts
of a young boy named Elliot to help an
endearing alien whom he discovers in his
backyard ET loudly announced Spielberg
is perhaps the greatest commercial
filmmaker alive it was a cultural
phenomenon easily the highest grossing
film of its year and it holds up
spectacularly today
[Music]
on the other end of the sci-fi spectrum
is Starship Troopers Paul Verhoeven's
bold dark satirical 1997 film very
loosely based on the Robert Heinlein
novel of the same name it's an
action-packed blood-soaked hilarious
good time with ver joven operating at
the peak of his craft the film
underperformed at the box office and
divided critics but it's satirical edge
has made it a cult classic in the years
since its release
both films will hit Netflix on June 1st
June is shaping up to be a great month
for dramatic films over at Netflix over
the next four weeks the streamer plans
to roll out everything from Academy
Award nominees to independent foreign
films and everything in between starting
on June 1st you'll be able to stream the
help and the classic musical West Side
Story among others the help is a popular
2011 period film based on the Kathryn
Stockett novel of the same name while
West Side Story is the definitive
feature film adaptation of the iconic
American Musical fortunately the eye
candy doesn't end there Netflix plans to
keep doling out the drama in a steady
flow throughout the month June 3rd will
see the release of Lady Bird a 2017 Best
Picture nominee from director Greta
Gerwig then on June 10th we get access
to middlemen a 2009 film about a man who
gets mixed up with the Russian mob June
12th brings a brand-new Spike Lee joint
the five Bloods starring chadwick
boseman the film follows four soldiers
who returned to Vietnam after the war to
look for treasure on the surface the
five Bloods looks something like a cross
between three kings and Apocalypse Now
but with Spike Lee at the helm you know
you're in for something brand new and
unforgettable finally Netflix plans to
round out the month with the foreign
film adieu an anthology film of sorts
that tells three interconnected stories
each taking place on the border between
Morocco and Spain look for that on the
30th there's never a bad time for
laughter and Netflix has got you covered
next month with a wide array of highbrow
lowbrow middlebrow and just about every
brow comedy you can imagine right at the
top of the month Netflix is poised to
drop a set of outstanding comedy films
spanning decades the earliest offering
on the list is 1976's Bad News Bears a
classic underdog sports comedy about a
washed-up alcoholic minor league
baseball player who takes on the
Herculean task of coaching a losing
little league team to success we also
get 1995's coming-of-age clueless the
film that made valley girl culture a
national phenomenon it stars Alicia
Silverstone Paul Rudd and the late
Brittany Murphy in a teen comedy for the
ages
if it's a concussion you have to keep
her conscious okay ask for question what
seven-ton says stuff she knows if you're
in the mood for something on the sillier
side Netflix has several notable options
for you available right away on June 1st
observe and report is a hilarious Seth
Rogen vehicle about a schlubby mall cop
on a mission to catch a flasher
terrorizing his turf walk hard the Dewey
Cox story written by Jake Kasdan and
Judd Apatow stars john c reilly in an
irreverent satire of the iconic Johnny
Cash biopic walk the line the right kid
is gonna die tonight and what comedy
list would be complete without a little
Sandman action you don't mess with the
Zohan is a classic Adam Sandler flick
concerning an Israeli special operator
who's grown weary with his violent life
and dreams of retiring as a hairstylist
mid-month dreamer plans to freshen up
its offerings with the addition of baby
mama a 2008 comedy starring Tina Fey as
a career woman who engages the services
of a reluctant layabout played by Amy
Poehler to be your pregnancy surrogate
what is water
horrible look for that on the 16th and
on June 26th Netflix is releasing
Eurovision Song Contest
the story of fire saga which concerns
two icelandic musicians vying for fame
and glory at the annual Eurovision
contest Will Ferrell and Rachel McAdams
have given us a glimpse of their
characters in the form of a music video
promising the kind of goofball comedy
that only Will Ferrell could deliver
given the wide variety June really does
have something for every comedy fan
while we might not associate the early
days of summer with spine-tingling
thrillers fans of the genre will tell
you that every season is horror season
if you're not or do fear rather because
Netflix has your back the streamers June
editions include horror and thriller
films new and old everything from tense
psychological thrillers to supernatural
gore fests beginning on the 1st of the
month
subscribers will have access to the
whole spectrum of rights you can settle
in with a plate of fava beans and nice
ki
to watch Anthony Hopkins as Hannibal
Lecter in Silence of the Lambs if
watching the famous cannibal
psychologically tormentors Clarice
doesn't do it for you he can always
navigate over to watch David Fincher's
zodiac a dramatized take on the
historical hunt for the Zodiac killer
the most prolific unsolved serial killer
case in modern history still not finding
anything to your liking 1991's Cape Fear
also streaming on the 1st of June is an
underappreciated psychological thriller
from Academy award-winning director
Martin Scorsese starring Robert De Niro
in one of his most unhinged roles ever
later in the month Netflix subscribers
can expect a new injection of horror
content in the form of to Blum house
productions first to arrive is Greg
McLean's terrifying supernatural horror
film The Darkness on June 16th the
darkness stars Kevin Bacon and Radha
Mitchell as unfortunate vacationers who
stumble upon an ancient evil on their
family trip to the Grand Canyon
after that flick has you hooked on Blum
House's unique aesthetic you can tune
into Scott Stewart's dark skies on June
22nd this 2013 science fiction horror
film stars Keri Russell Josh Hamilton
and the incomparable JK Simmons as the
residents of an unnamed American city
gripped by mysterious phenomena for the
last few years Netflix has been giving a
platform to the boldest and brightest
stars of the comedy world the trend will
continue in June 2020 when three very
distinct stand-up specials from masters
of the craft drop on the streaming
platform if you're in need of a good
belly laugh you know where to turn On
June 12th
you can catch a Netflix first comedian
jo koy whom you'll recognize from his
previous Netflix stand-up specials or
his stint as a panelist on Chelsea
Lately filmed his latest special in the
Philippines jo koy in his elements isn't
just stand-up though the comedian
brought along a group of fellow Filipino
American entertainers who had never been
to the island nation before to celebrate
their culture with a lot of love and a
lot of laughs
specials by two bona fide
comedy legends are dropping later in the
month on June 23rd Eric Andre makes his
Netflix debut with a new special that
sees the comedian tackling issues as
diverse as the war on drugs - the
legitimacy of fart jokes you can follow
that up on June 30th with another
Netflix debut from a comedy veteran
George Lopez provides some of his
signature humorous and heartfelt
insights on politics race and Latino
culture in his latest special will do it
for half fans of Netflix original series
are going to have a bountiful start to
their summer in June the streaming
service is dropping new seasons of some
of its most well-loved shows as well as
plenty of other series to keep you up
late hitting play next episode in the
first half of the month we're getting
the final season of the family-friendly
reboot fuller house on the second and
the final installment of the teen drama
series 13 reasons why on the fifth also
on the fifth you can binge all three
seasons of Brian Fuller's visually
arresting and psychologically complex
taken one of literature's favorite
serial killers Hannibal as well as the
new season of the reality hit queer eye
on the seventh look for new episodes of
Emmy award-winning news and cultural
show Patriot Act with Hasan Minhaj
recent seasons of twisty nighttime soaps
queen of the south and how to get away
with murder will also hit Netflix on
June 6th and 13th respectively you'll
also be able to stream the second season
of the groundbreaking drama Poe's
arriving on the 11th later in the month
keep an eye out for the second seasons
of comedian Gabriel Iglesias sitcom mr.
Iglesias on the 17th followed by the
return of two hugely popular Netflix
originals on the 18th Netflix is
dropping the second season of their
original dark fantasy series the order
the first season was chock-full of magic
werewolves and drama and it looks like
the next installment is going to get
even Wilder the day after that you can
catch the next season of Ryan Murphy's
high-stakes political drama d the
politician
[Music]
summer days maybe heading our way but
clearly netflix is doing it best to keep
us all inside check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite stuff
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the belt so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]